things have exploded over the anime
video tweeted out by republican
congressman paul gozar in which a
cartoon version of him sort of anime his
face on it a cart an anime version of
paul gozar is depicted as killing
democratic congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez the demands now range from
investigate through a house ethics panel
to
arrest
paul gozar to send the fbi
to paul gozar to talk to him about this
there's also a sort of hypocrisy
component to this which i'm going to
talk about but it is a wild wild story
so let's start with newsweek reporting
paul gozar faces growing calls to be
arrested
over video showing him killing aoc
killing aoc
congressman paul gosar is facing calls
to be arrested or expelled from congress
after the lawmaker shared an anime video
depicting him killing congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez in most jobs in
most jobs if it's determined that during
your off time whatever that means
you are tweeting videos
depicting you killing a co-worker you
would be fired
you would be fired you would be fired
okay it's just not even it's not even
there's not even a debate about it um
congressman gosar sparked fierce
backlash on sunday after he tweeted an
anime video showing him killing
congresswoman ocasio-cortez the video
based on the anime attack on titan shows
gozar killing the new york lawmaker with
a sword before launching himself at
president joe biden
within hours the tweet went viral as of
tuesday morning had been viewed more
than 3.2 million times the video and
depiction of violence against aoc led
numerous figures to call for congressman
gozar to be arrested or expelled from
congress democrats critics call for
action against congressman paul gozar
over his grotesque post uh this is uh
from huffington post in any workplace in
america if a co-worker made an anime
video killing another co-worker that
person would be fired my sentiment
exactly more than half a dozen house
dems one house republican and scores of
critics have condemned and called for
action against paul gosar monday after
he posted a doctored anime video that
depicts him killing congresswoman aoc
gosar tweeted an edited version of the
opening credits of the japanese anime
series attack on titan showing himself
as the main character who then slashes
the neck of a foe with ocasio-cortez's
face um aoc tweeted about it so while i
was on route to glasgow a creepy member
i work with who fundraises for neo-nazi
groups that's true shared a fantasy
video of him killing me and he'll face
no consequences because gop leader kevin
mccarthy cheers him on with excuses fun
monday well back to work
and then just another aspect to this
which media matters
covered goes-r tweet reveals a double
standard in cable news's coverage of
extremism and civility in 2019 cable
news devoted more attention to a
democratic congresswoman cursing than
it's now giving to a republican
congressman tweeting an anime video of
killing a colleague um
this is a reference to well there's a
couple of different things so first of
all
remember the incident where steve steve
king rather embraced white supremacy and
then there was when rashida talib said
impeach the mfr so you go back and you
look at cnn fox news and msnbc they all
devoted overwhelmingly more time to
rasheeda talib cursing versus steve king
embracing white supremacy and we're
seeing the point from um
uh media matters here is that we're
seeing the exact same dynamic play out
uh with this situation now one other
funny thing about paul gozar and it's
not even really that funny
uh he has a whole bunch of siblings like
it's one of these families where there's
just kids upon kids upon kids there's a
very interesting um video
where back in 2018 his siblings endorsed
his opponent and the ad is very cleverly
done where you don't know until later
that these are all his siblings at first
it just kind of sounds like it's random
people saying i don't like paul gozar
check this out this is this is a good
one paul gosar the congressman
isn't doing anything to help
rural america paul's absolutely not
working for his district if they care
about health care they care about their
children's health care
they would hold him to account if they
care about jobs
they would hold him to account if he
actually cared about people in rural
arizona
i bet he'd be fighting for social
security for better access to health
care i better he i bet he would be
researching what is the most insightful
water policy to help the environment of
arizona sustain itself
and be successful and he's not listening
to you and he doesn't have your
interests at heart my name is tim gosar
david gosar grace gosar joan gosar
gaston gosar jennifer gosar paul gosar
is my brother my brother and i endorse
dr grill dr brill wholeheartedly endorse
dr david brill for congress um gosar
really is one of the most disgusting
members of congress will there be
consequences for tweeting a video
glamorizing drama dramatizing him
killing a colleague
unfortunately there probably will not
there probably will not
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcasts too
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blinkist for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below